i
[Music]
well
[Music] I
wanted to take advantage of this time to share
with you and the reflections
that we have made about the
digital transformation in the entity the
first
the first the first is not new but
we believe that it is relevant here the world
is changing
that  It is not changing very fast.
On the one hand, we are in an
increasingly global world. This means
that small information is easier
to access to global competition. I
would try to access more global clients.
On the other hand, technology has gone from
simply supporting processes.  of business
to provide competitive advantages
directly and 6 more of logic is
causing us to change the way we
work and the way we
relate to each other
and this means that,
as I have said, we are in a moment of
exponential change that is obviously
a great opportunity for everyone
to all the others for all of you
also has enormous challenges
especially for traditional companies
what  leads us to the second reflection
this west of the seat so many times
more entities digital initiatives that
fail that do not go well it is difficult to
maintain
material digital initiatives that
live up to expectations on the one
hand and on the other because
this digital training generic initiatives
digital a complex which
leads us to reflect
on why the problems that there are
many fail we have focused on three things
that are possibly the most relevant the
first the typical focus
exclusively on
digital transformation technologies important the most
important transformation than digital
transforming implies changing implies
leaving what we were before to do
something different and this is done by
both people and organizations because of
the few incentives to do so because
as it has gone well for us so far because
changing costs a lot you are going to change it
does something you don't  you know well
is disturbing and for the organizations  tions
ceases to be a plane of people because it is
even more to see this, we only have
to see the sectors that have truly
embraced
digitization, such as these
media or the music sector that is
most popular, although by reproduction
and
trusting all the digital experts
is not a good idea either digital
we can help in the transformation and
we can accelerate the transformation but
of course we all know that any
change has to start from within if
we want it to be a real change
with which someone
from  similar to the training of
gypsies or what happens in a department
group of people
within or next to your organization
digital by
definition digital by definition includes the
entire organization and therefore it has to be
the leaders that you be the leaders
of  the organization
the leaders proposals
any of these occurrences
occurrence of more some more
some just realize
and  we just call it the digital one,
it's not the same, the other one, as you can see, the
plant counts a
lot
batman
1 faces
like me you will have sure the second
superego of important euros of the
greats that doesn't have any batman superpower
and take all the villains with
training
with  determination with a courage with
preparation obviously technology
then the news is good
any of us can be the
batman of business if you do not allow
it the only thing is that please we have to
try the treatment we are not more or
less clear we have to try to
face excellence
I think it is in this world that
asking about change changes the
potential so much competition doing
things well I think enough
is enough which leads us to the next lesson
before all that training
we are clear that all these
socioeconomic transformations
next technology
more diligent artificial if the
combination of all of them
as we are going to do  ptar we have it clear and
how and when exactly where our
sectors that moments are
getting faster and more
intense but what we can do and
what I do believe is the duty of your
leaders as leaders of
these organizations is
we have a digital dynamic digital dynamic
is one that allows our employees to grow and
improve
where they are and with
what you have
the objective is to
help these employees to be digital
to gradually
create digital solutions and products
that can lead to other customers and
products  digital solutions to
solutions and products that provide
differential competitive advantages
which leads us to the following
reflection and that is how we do
popular collaboration
developed a fairly
detailed methodology and
very well thought out with a lot of experience
because we will be happy to share
with you
onetoone here we have tried to
conceptualize
if we want to change  ar the culture that we have
said that we want to change part that
makes sense in
values that we all understand are useful and n
cessary in it on th
way i
novation simplicity trans
arency efficiency these
values are what define what organizatio
as our organizatio
s are the  organization small problems that
are not measurable you can tell me
today I am 42% innovative and in
six months I want to be 62% it is impossible
so what we do is ground the
values and behaviors the behav
ors if they are measurable and their asset
and are  impr
if you can measure
if you want to be a collaborator if they can
come how many shared documents
access how you share your agenda are
more concrete things and can say
how many of how many people clearly
these behaviors promote
innovation this training that we are
looking for to differentiate them to
survive
and this training innovation  will in
turn change the  culture in the sense
that we want and thus creating what
the circles of the digital league have created,
which is that it aims to break precisely the
vicious type of history of the part,
the traditional companies,
old for 5 years, want to
leave, which leads us to a small reflection
next
the behaviors of the values the conce
ts about the current ones and the behav
or and that is what we have
ad news about the moment we stop
y experience the moment we stop
cting on the behav
ors in the circle the v
cious circle of digit
l dynamics  it stops we return to where
we were even a little worse and
we return to expectations because we have
disappointed expectations that we have created
with which we are even before
where to start the good news is that
the average talde
that I think we do google with its
technological innovation
the tool  collaboration together with the
digital mind
the deep management ability of the
change  bio digital and the capacity that
we have to implement
google technologies but that we are going to make a
powerful new one to achieve this
that is of this digital dynamic
simply show the applications and
that they follow their own their own
their own flow their own their own
energy
but if your employees do not buy the
transformation according to their employees it
does not row in that sense our
employees do not endorse the
transformation and it was changed
before finishing it allows a small
summary of the digital training
from within led by the villas of
the organization the objective is  create a
digital dynamic digital dynamic that
allows our employees to
be digital that little by little you can
release products in an
isolated and sadop way but rather in a
systematic way differential digital products and solutions
that allow us to
succeed and continue working as we
have done in the past
and what takes the last the last
reflection
to end and  is that please it
is only a request with a reflection please
we ask you
not to do digital 6 digital once
digital fisher digital
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]